I'm Sarah Groff Hennigh-Palermo.
On Twitter, I'm super SGP, so, if you like
the opinions you hear today, there are way
more of them on the internet.
So, up until very recently, I was an engineer
at Kickstarter.
I left about a month ago to have a career
crisis and find myself, but that's what I
used to do.
When I'm not coding for money, I'm actually
coding for art.
I do live code as well.
Those SVGs I make with clojure scripts, hand
made artisanal SVGs in Brooklyn.
I'm here to talk about errors.
I have a lot to say, I realised by the way,
when crying writing this talk, that it's four
talks.
Rather than make it shorter, I decided that
I was going to talk really fast, so, if some
of the slides go by fast, you don't read the
code, don't worry, it's going to be on the
internet.
There's lots of links with, like, details
so you can see it all later.
So, let's get started.
Lately, I've become super interested in the
way that we approach errors, as programmers,
as a culture, and I wasn't going to start
off telling you why I got interested because
I felt it was incendiary, but I decided to
go ahead and tell you now and hope you keep
on listening if you think I'm insane.
I'm interested in errors because I really
hate types.
I know that that is not, like, a really popular
opinion here in 2018, right?
This idea that I, as someone who only knows
some programming thinks that I know way better
than all these computer sifts who have done
research and told us that types are like THE
way to do it right.
But I know that type errors are real, and
so I was like, "Well, if I wasn't going to
be into these, how would I have a better way
to approach errors?"
I decided to do some research.
Luckily, errors are really interesting.
On the one hand, they're this cursed object
that explodes rockets, overdoses people on
radiation, and makes webforms refuse to submit
when you need them the most.
As such, they're a danger around which every
right-thinking person is furiously erecting
fences, right?
But, on the other hand, errors are kind of
hilarious, so, consider the case of Nuclear
Ghandi.
In the very first Civilisation game, for some
reason, towards the end of the game, Ghandi
would suddenly become incredibly aggressive
and start threatening to nuke everyone which,
with , if you know Ghandi, it's kind of unlike
him, right?
It turned out that aggressiveness was unrepresented
with an unsigned byte when Ghandi was set
to 1 and took an action like democracy, it
flipped around to to 255 and gave Ghandi Max
aggression.
Players like it so much that it is still used
even though the mechanism has been discovered
and understood.
Errors can make us inventive.
In Win Commander, the game completed an out-of-memory
error, and the programmers could not figure
out why it was showing this error.
Sometimes, you've got to shift.
So they changed the error message to a message
of congratulations and went on with their
day.
Errors can also be delightful.
So, when I was working on my life code framework
doing some animations, I forgot that rotations
needed to be stable from frame to frame.
I accidentally made a circle friend, because
animation - [sound breaking up].
Sometimes, we feel this way about CSS.
You know, we [sound breaking up].
Errors can be terrible and amazing.
Maybe if they're terrible, we should just
cool it and not worry about what we are missing
out on.
Something I noticed is that examples of interesting
errors come from things like games and art,
and bad errors come from things like health
care, and rockets.
But fortunately, as web programmers, we're
much closer to the former, even though, as
a culture, we tend to act as though we are
the latter, and we really think beyond how
to fix errors.
It is not really a big surprise, actually,
so, culturally and philosophically, we are
trained to deny and avoid error in pretty
much every aspect of our lives.
As in the book being Wrong - which, with , by
the way, is a book, when people see you reading
it, they want to talk to you - this view is
common and common with heavy-hitters in history
- Plato - and it comes from the idea that
errors are a product of a gap between the
true world and our flawed human minds as we
attempt to interpret it.
This is the view that effectives us a yearning
for correctness.
However, there is also an optimistic view
of erring, and in this modern view, originating
in the Enlightenment, the idea that this gap
is a perception and can be faced and overcome
as we move towards truth.
In fact, seeing the world perfectly as it
is might not even be the right goal.
As Schulz writes, seeing the world as it's
not is the definition of erring but also the
essence of invention, imagination, and hope.
This gap may also just be the downside to
our massively great inductive reasoning upsides.
All the short cuts we take that make humans
such good planters, inventors, like intuitive
little plants, right, means we may misperceive.
We can risk it up.
I'm going to talk a little bit more today
about what we mean by errors, how we deal
in JavaScript now, situate that historically,
and then go ahead and see what other options
might be available to us in the future.
What do we mean by errors?
There are a lot of different schemes that
people have come up to answer this question.
A lot of the times, they split along the lines
of whether it's an avoidable programmer error,
or an unavoidable universe fairly - like we
see here from the first edition of Eloquent
JavaScript.
I don't think that's the most helpful way
to look at it.
If errors are inevitable to us as humans,
then that's just as much a universe failure
as anything else.
The framework I like comes from Slips, Mistakes,
and Failures by Tomas Petricek.
This is by the magnitude.
Slips are where your idea was right and you
try to encode it the right way but you made
a sin tax error or typo.
I feel these as errors we don't ship because
they break right away, the linter catches
them.
The other end of the generality spectrum,
we have mistakes where you made a error thinking
through the specification.
That's really fuzzy.
You like - like what does the specification
even mean?
I think of a mistake has building the wrong
thing.
In the middle, we have failures where you
have the right idea but encoded some part
of it poorly.
This is what we are most concerned with day
to day.
How do we deal with these failure-type errors?
JavaScript?
JavaScript using a type of exception handling
that is about half the original system used
in PL1 in 1968.
There is PL1 up there in the language family
tree descending from Fortran and Algol.
In JavaScript, exception handling arrived
in ES3 and worked as it does today - we have
the error prototype to construct errors, we
have the throw key word to propagate them,
we have try, catch, and finally, to create
a new lexical environment to handle exceptions,
and then to clean up after their mess that
wasn't be fixed by setting the lexical environment.
One thing that surprised me in my research
is there used to be a non-standard multi-catch
syntax, so instead of having to put a conditional
catch, you can do catch, catch, catch, catch,
but that's not been there since Firefox 59
so that boat kind of sailed.
In addition to user-defined errors, there
are six built-in error types - only five of
them are still thrown.
EvalError exists for backwards compatibility.
The biggest change arrived with early errors,
strict mode, to make sure there is no code
in memory that's not going to execute.
And, to disallow code that would otherwise
be allowed by the grammar.
These are reported when the programme is evaluated,
not when it's run, so it's not part of our
exception-handling scheme.
Inside the exception-handling system, things
are pretty much as they are in most other
languages, but in this case, common is not
a synonym for opt hall.
When the invoking function is able to use
catch to respond to an error, the stack traces
available but the evoking function cannot
detect code anywhere down the stack itself.
Consider this example.
There is this parse entry function which throws
an exception when it can't parse a file, and
it's getting called four functions in two
lines deep, maybe it's inside a library, and
this able ise all files is in your code.
When it fails in throws, we might as a programmer
have an idea of a good default we can use
to continue so the parsing can keep going
and we don't have to unwind the loops.
If only we had a default, we would rewrite
the function to account for the fact that
you can return a default value, but I think
you can see how making this the responsibility
of this inner function both breaks encapsulation,
and can quickly get out of hand if you had
ideas for other sorts of interventions.
So we might be able to do something, but it
doesn't matter, because it is not possible
without preprocessing the data or rerunning
the entire function.
Other changes to exception handling have come
obviously in JavaScript with promises and
asynch await.
These haven't changed the basic concept, though.
They've extended it.
They've made for interesting corner cases
and variations.
For instance, if you return from a nested
finally, you're never going to call your outside
handler, so never print banana, which is very
tragic.
Errors may also remain entirely uncaught by
a chained catch.
I didn't realise this until I was messing
around.
That first promise isn't going to be caught
by the catch.
There's a proposal for promise.try that would
address this, but currently, that's a big
sticking point.
Then with the sink await, the variations in
pitfalls go further.
My friend Frances had a fun bug where using
in function, log stats was being thrown twice.
It turned out an external function used by
log stats was throwing, and being caught surprised
him because he was thinking of that for the
await, so he came up with some solutions.
You could just only wrap the await in a try
block, which is what a lot of people have
done.
If you have a lot of async, it leads to a
ton of trying, obviously.
You can use the goify pattern where where
you create a Proms that returns an error,
so you're handling errors on a per-promise
basis.
Or you could change the catch, but as we discussed
before, this won't catch and it the promise
throws.
There are a lot of variations with implicit
pattern trade-offs.
At the base, it is the same try-catch Americanism.
It is worth noting before I go on, that the
DOM does provide error event listeners.
I've never seen them used in production, and
I didn't even know about them, so if anyone
is actually using this, please come and talk
to me because I'm really curious how you're
doing it.
Basically, this is JavaScript's fairly unexceptional
exception system.
It has some funny little corners, and, on
the one hand, it is super unremarkable, yet
it seems strange that such a remarkable language
built to be so dynamic for all the good and
ill that that implies and bound strongly to
its earlier choices of its commitment to the
to break the web, has an anime ic way of dealing
with errors.
It is this lack of balance that I suspect
sometimes leads to JavaScript's reputation
as a problem child, or a foot gun, and, lately,
the answer to that has been to dial down the
dynamism.
As I've mentioned before, I'm not super into
that solution.
I've written and spoken about this before.
If you're interested later, DM me.
But the short version of the argument is:
the choice s are poor limit ed effort into
a static type system in JavaScript both in
tooling and in day-to-day product engineering
is a mistake.
Type-checking only catches type errors and
there will always be points of failure in
an application that deals with networking,
user input and the DOM.
One of my broadest type-based achievements
is I've actually thrown a runtime error in
Elm which people say is impossible but it
turns out when you're appending strings to
the DOM, no-one can really save you!
Also, though, maybe being saved isn't so great.
Maybe being so correct forces us to correct
huge unwieldy systems, and, being small and
composable makes your programmes easy to understand,
even if slightly more error-prone.
Making working with computers in a tight iterative
loop is just more pleasurable, and maybe looking
at computers as conversation partners instead
of half cop, half servant, is better for us
as human beings.
These are all good reasons to give error-handling
a second look.
There is also I think a political and aesthetic
reason to move away from solution through
specification.
The idea that the best way to be safe is to
make being unsafe illegal has deep roots in
computer science's positivist history.
This approach blocks out the strange, the
hybrid, the human.
It prevents us from discovering weird mistakes
like shaky shapes.
Politically, it harms us by insisting only
strong categories are valid and denying liminal
spaces.
Consider the US census.
Up until I was 20, you were only allowed to
pick one race.
Because that's what the system could handle.
But that's not true.
I am not one race, like that's not the answer.
And it took more work and the acceptance of
loser categories for the system even to reflect
some portion of that truth.
The same can be said for gender identity,
right?
There are not two answers or not four.
The idea that we should restrict ourselves
to communicating in a way a machine should
understand instead of working them to be partners
seems to me to be the path to a barren future.
I'm going to talk about errors in history
and see where we really came from.
If we arrange general error-handling methods
from the dramatic to the subtle, and this
list comes from Chris Hauzer, exception-handling
comings right in the middle.
At the top, the most dramatic option is just
to crash.
This is obviously the original classic direct
from Fortran.
And it makes sense when a computer is a glorified
calculator and you have a knowledgeable operator
sitting right there, right?
Why keep doing calculations if they're going
to be wrong, crash, and fix it.
In modern times, this can be anywhere from
inconvenient to really terrible.
So, for instance been recently, the New York
City subway replaced signals, including a
computerised signal.
It turned out the switch had a bug and the
only way to work work on it or fix it was
to reboot the subway, which took a really
long time, and was incredibly inconvenient.
In this case, just crashing was probably not
the best idea.
Between just crashing and doing an exception
is the idea to enter a debugger, which you
might be familiar with very much in a Rails
environment, you can enter the debugger, and
the switch engineers would maybe have appreciated
this approach to rebooting the train.
Less dramatically, you can return a special
value.
This approach is pretty uncommon in modern
languages, except for some utility functions.
Find index will return negotiate perspective
one and callback where errors - this approach
suffers from the semi-predicate problem which
is to say that you have to check for it explicitly.
That's its biggest downfall.
Even more deprecated as an approach, and one
of the first solutions after just crashing,
is to set an error flag.
This was common in things like BASIC.
And I think you can see how setting an error
flag, returning a value, would lead to throwing
an exception, even further outside to help
the system deal with it.
Finally, we have the least dramatic option
which is to recover and keep going.
Why hide errors?
Only - context and possibilities for recovery
really matter here.
This is what HTML does, for instance, right?
Maybe you didn't close a tag but you can still
read the text.
Even though it can seem impractical, at times,
it is the most practical.
I learned from Wikipedia, when I was working
on this, that the default IEE754 floating-point
exception-handling behaviour is resume computation
following the substitute of a default value
if you have an arithmetic error.
This would have prevented the 1996 explosion
which was caused in part by the fact that
Ada just aborted computation on an arithmetic
error like an integer overflow.
Finally, we can add a few other elements to
the list of ways to we have historically dealt
with errors.
You can send a signal which is a little bit
different from a return value, because anyone
can listen for it, but you're not throwing
it.
And there are option types and maybes which
could possibly fall under Keep Going.
Some approaches can be seen as a combination.
Erlang is signal plus crash plus recover.
That's sort of where we are.
Let's look at where we could go.
This is the last section.
There are a lot of different routes we could
take to expand our approaches to errors and
adjust our relationships to machines.
Where I think I want to see computing go in
the future, I keep coming back to this tweet
from Emilia McNamara contrasting traditional
programme language goals, correctness, performance,
to new ones like modifiability and learnability.
In particular, I think about error-handling
method as involve these last two - modifiability,
and learnability.
To get there, we might think of things like
robust ways of nullability like it is today,
and that is coming, there's the optional training
proposal which I think is in stage one that
would, by reducing the number of checks for
small quotidian errors, free us up to focus
on exception handling, might pair with expanding
ways to work with errors as events and focusing
on good default arguments, focusing on defaults
leads us into a more broad look at robustness
and in addition to rigour which is to say
looking for things that will bend and not
break.
That makes recovery more possible and less
disruptive.
This might look like augmenting or rebuilding
the current exception system.
Remember, when I mentioned that JavaScript
succession is only half a system compared
to PL1?
It's described in the canonical paper from
1971.
Exception mechanisms are not just needed to
deal with errors.
They're needed in general in a way of interleaving
actions belonging to different levels of abstraction.
They're not necessarily really activated,
so this involves moving responsibility up
the stack but not necessarily unwind ing errors
which is to say that context is maintained.
It proposes a specification for exception
that is have three types - escape, signal,
and notify - which can require termination,
be the colour's choice, or forbid termination.
It is these capabilities hacked off from C++
due to termination back in 1989 that, since
no-one really used them in Cedar, no-one should
have them in their exception-handling ever
again.
If we want to leave the past in the past,
a focus on robustness can be maintaining good
state in user interaction.
For instance, I use Figure Wheel for live
code.
When I make an error, it keeps the last good
state going, while telling me that I've created
an error.
React's error boundaries also do the same
thing.
If you imagine combining this existence with
maintaining good state with the ability to
access a production Ralph, we could do all
sorts of crazy, good I've fixes that wouldn't
hurt users.
What would continuous deployment be like if
you deployed an error, identified it in.
Repo made a hot fix in one restartable module?
That could be an amazing way to go back and
forth with your system when you define errors.
Then, if we got really crazy, we could look
at stealing good ideas from even further afield.
One is recovery blocks.
This is a pattern where you create an acceptance
test.
You give a list of ways to attempt a successful
result, and then, if all of those fail, then,
you know, then the error is thrown, and the
acceptance test usually can access variables
from before and after the functions are run,
so that works for pre- and post-conditions
or domain and range errors.
Another option would be an algebraic handlers
in things like F, handling errors in a mow
nomadic style.
If you're not familiar with camel syntax,
this may not make a ton of sense.
K, which is the continuation, so you can intervene
and pick up where the language left off lexically.
Finally, we could just head for the stratosphere
and consider ways to reframe our relationships
with computers.
We could make computers a full partner with
programme-slicing and better automatic suggestions.
The Rossette language extends racket to use
solvers and synthesise code.
We could also take the alternate approach,
and work to reframe computers from something
that just works to something that maybe tinkered
with and grow and might not be this machine
for brutal effectiveness.
Some of these seem really big.
And really fast, and very undetailed.
But it's only by wanting more that we are
going to get explorations into getting more.
There is something we can do today: that is
to make it culturally acceptable, even encouraged,
to spend time thinking about ways to fail
well instead of not trying to fail altogether.
And so, in terms of encouragement, I have
one last quote for you again from being wrong.
"We want to turn away from error because it
reminds us of our existential despair, that
we are separate from truth, and from one another,
but also the only true way to engage and to
create, and imagine, is to risk error."
So, let's not cut ourselves off at the knees
by underestimating ourselves and our machines.
Maybe let's not be afraid.
Instead, let's make it safe to take some risks
and throw some errors, and then to continue.
Thank you guys so much!
[Cheering and Applause].